seventy-five million Americans will be
in the grip of an extreme heat wave
today temperatures will soar into the
90s in the Northeast it'll feel like
triple digits in cities from Washington
and Philadelphia to Bangor Maine and
Manchester New Hampshire and the heats
expected to stick around through
Independence Day DeMarco Morgan's on the
beach in Long Branch New Jersey the
Marco good morning good morning to you
it's a lot cooler and fog you're out
here but that will soon change but reach
goers we get a chance to jump into the
water just to stay cool but that's not
the case for folks like construction
workers the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention says most people who are
outside and who work in these conditions
are more vulnerable to heat stress and
that could lead to heatstroke and heat
exhaustion
laying the foundation for a new building
right by the beach tom Albertini and his
team are surrounded by steel and
concrete as they battle the sweltering
heat with water soaked rags and scarves
wrapped around their necks to keep cool
there's buckets of water all over the
site if they have to get out of the Sun
we got them coming to the trailer they
have their own trailers they can cool
off on and you know then they'll get
right back to it
Jim Burrell also works out some I'm
checking the refrigerant pressure to
keep people cool inside he's been at the
air-conditioning business for nearly 50
years and has seen a spike in calls
during the heat wave I'm probably doing
that 8 or 10 quarts a day generally
issues New Jersey about 50 elderly
residents were evacuated from this
nursing home after the air-conditioning
and they're building malfunctioned they
were taken to other facilities run by
the same company and a septa train on
its way to New Jersey was halted in
Philadelphia because of a mechanical
issue passengers said they were stuck on
the train for more than an hour without
air conditioning
they were later transferred to another
train back in the Northeast Life Guards
in the New Jersey beach town of Sigurd
have rescued or assisted nearly 100
swimmers since the weekend as more
people head down the shore and to other
beaches in the region we knew it was
gonna be hot mark Zingo and his daughter
took the boat out in Connecticut to try
and stay cool but under the 84 degrees
Sun it felt more like was 95 it's rough
it's a lot harder than I thought it was
gonna be but it was fun
beaches like this will be packed
tomorrow for the fourth of July holiday
weekend but you know what folks
the temperatures are calling for mid 80s
but the heat index will make it feel
more like it's in the mid nineties so
yell if you're heading out here stay
hydrated
alright good advice for anybody heading
out there Thank You DeMarco